Justin Bieber canceled the rest of his  purpose world tour dates what do you  mean  [Music]  the show's over people the Biebs  canceled the remaining 14 stops on his  world tour Monday including stadiums all  over the US Canada Japan the Philippines  and Singapore the 23 year olds camp  released a statement explaining quote  unforeseen circumstances led to the  decision  adding Justin loves his fans and hates  to disappoint them  however after careful consideration he  has decided he will not be performing  any further dates while he didn't  exactly address why he's pulling the  plug on the final leg of his tour we  kept that ocean  get that over at or source tolls ET  quote this is a guy who has had 150  shows on this tour on six continents  over the last year in half and he's  tired he needed a break  ET reached out to Justin's camp for  comment but has not received word back  tickets will be refunded for the  canceled dates  [Music]